hey everybody and welcome to another hd
or hq video i should say because i'm
using this new camera here and first
thing i want to tell you about is that
this is going to be a video in response
to one of my much earlier videos um in
which i went over the media center
remote for my new hp laptop this is the
hp pavilion dv7 t and which i'll get to
in a second but i'm going to going to go
over some of the features i couldn't
actually show you while using the webcam
on the laptop itself because i couldn't
show you what was going on on the screen
as i press certain buttons so here i'm
going to actually pick up the camera and
i don't have a tripod yet so bear with
me but i'm going to show you what
actually happens on the screen when you
press different buttons and there's a
few of the different features in windows
media player in windows vista okay
here's the setup and pardon number one
the shaking and number two the not so
great quality but i have the remote here
in my hand and i'll be showing you how
to control the laptop with the remote so
first of all at the top you see this
green button right here i told you
before is the meteor center button now
right here on the laptop is actually the
infrared receiver you might not be able
to see that but that's where it receives
the infrared signal so i'm just going to
press that media center button and
windows vista home premium 64-bit should
pick it up and open up windows media
center here we go here's the media
center that's the first thing that comes
up and in fact i'm going to go ahead and
plug in my headphones to give you guys a
better experience so you can hear the
sounds and everything that are
associated with every movement so here
i'm going to plug in these speakers here
so here is i'll zoom in on my screen a
little bit this is the media center
interface i still have the remote in
hand here and you can see there's a lot
of different things we can do if i
scroll up and down using the remote or
the arrow keys so i'll use the uh the
remote for this example we have a tv
we have
music we have all the music library all
the photos and videos there's also tasks
which is interesting i'll get to that in
a minute online media which i use a lot
quick play and sports so i'll start with
music what you have in music is your
music library
okay you can play all the music this
will search your entire hard drive for
your music library so keep in mind
that's going to search all of your music
you can pl you can listen to internet
radio and you can also search your music
which is a long and tedious process
without the keyboard but i'll just go
into my media library so you can see
when you select it with the center
button on the remote it actually brings
up the entire thing you can obviously
scroll to the right and it kind of it's
reminiscent of cover flow it's very
smooth animation
um animation wise so it's very good
graphics if you don't like the graphics
you can always turn them off in the
settings
also if i go up here i can search by
artist album genre go down here and
choose my electronic and dance and it'll
sort them out for me so there we go
now if i ever want to go back i just
have to hit this back button right here
on the bottom left hand corner of the
remote just harass it once
twice three times and we're back to our
main menu
i'm going to scroll up here to picture
and video because i do have a little bit
of picture and video media on my hard
drive right now as you can see i have a
few pictures this is actually a picture
folder on my hard drive which is cool
because it knows that it's a folder if i
click on it
it's opening up right here you can see
this is all my pictures so if i this is
my logo i click on it again
i can scroll through my logos folder all
the logos i've made okay i can scroll
down and through this pictures folder
and view any one picture full screen
that's a cute puppy but in the click of
a button so that's pretty cool that you
can do that and again i like the
animations so that's pretty cool that
you can do that using this remote also
if you're in the middle of a song um
hopefully this will focus a little bit
here but you have the rewind the play
pause and the fast forward and also the
stop buttons so at any time you can use
those buttons to control your media your
movie whatever apps to be playing also
i'm going to go over hp quick play which
is a whole separate um a whole separate
video review basically for you guys
and pardon the mic quality you might not
be able to understand everything here
but i'm just going to go back
and i'm going to scroll down now to show
you guys the sports section which is one
of the other sections i use now i do not
have a tv tuner so i'll just cancel
because i haven't got it built in but
you can actually check scores and a lot
more than just scores so i'll click on
this here you can check a lot more than
just scores using the remote alright and
pardon me not using camtasia studio 6
because i wanted to show you guys this
and its actual interaction with the
laptop so here you can see across the
top as i scroll across see basketball
baseball
or i actually have to go up first but
you can see the different scores this is
the final after triple overtime dang
and even games that are underway are
still used are still highlighted
so if we're to click on a game that's
still highlighted here we go the bobcats
and the timberwolves that's the score
and we can go to fox sports and just
take a look at what they've reported for
us about the game and this is all free
built into windows vista media center
okay
so i really like that feature there you
go that's
that's one of the match-ups we've got
going on right now so i'm just going to
hit back
back back
and that is basically what i'm going to
show you guys for now but if i were to
show you more about windows media center
remote that would basically be it okay
you don't have a whole lot of extra
features here it's the basic you have
the channel up and down
sorry about that you have the channel up
and down up and down right here you have
the volume buttons the uh the mute
button is right here the volume up and
the volume down obviously you have your
navigation controls in there
your uh skip song to the right or skip
song backwards
again the media center uh the media
player controls also these left and
right arrows can be used when you're
sorting through pictures
and this eye right here is the
information button again not that much
else this one is to watch the dvd
directly and that's basically it so i
hope you enjoy
again your windows media center laptop
and if you do get the media center
remote with again only hp laptops you
will enjoy this pretty sweet feature
also you can watch kind of a sort of
news
newscast kind of thing like if i were to
go in here
um to online media and i were to hit uh
explore
it'll actually take me to an online
guide of shows that i can watch and uh
different live casts that i can actually
tune into at any time without a tv tuner
so that's pretty cool
so anyway thanks for watching this
review and i hope you like it if you
have any other tutorial requests or
video requests or comments please
message me please ask me i do the best i
can
that's basically it
so thanks for watching this video thanks
for tuning in thanks for subscribing and
see you later guys peace